greetings you bad [__] welcome
to the joint it's brought to you by
freeze pipe get an ice cold hit every
time here's how it works the pipe comes
with a detachable chamber that you
freeze beforehand when you're ready to
[__] see the devil the hot smoke
passes through the frozen part cooling
down the smoke as you [__] inhale
poof you're in colorado with uncle joey
up in the mountains you understand me i
love the freeze pipe i have the pipe i
thought i had the bubbler the bubble is
on display but i got the pipe and i got
a big [__] bung but i'm not ready for
that yet i'm happy with the [__] pipe
it takes me where i gotta be i put a hit
of [__] uh laughing gas and that
[__]
it's time it's not non-toxic freezes
faster than water and stays frozen
longer freeze pipe cools down the smoke
by hundreds of degrees i know you guys
love them you got a bunch of them for
[__] christmas but i tell you what
they're still on [__] fire so do me a
favor for the joint listeners go to
freezepipe.com
press and code joey j-o-e-y and i'm
gonna save you 10 off your first door
that's a deal get the bomb the pipe or
the bubbler or get all [__] three of
them if you're professional that's the
freezepipe.com
and pressing code joey to save 10
[__] percent if you can smoke from it
freeze pipe [__] makes it i think
they're
putting together like a dead finger you
can sneak out it and the [__] toenail
is a [__] iceberg anyway the joint is
also brought to you by [__]
draftkings the nfl playoffs are here
and draftking sportsbook the official
sports betting part of the nfl is
kicking things off especially tonight
you got arizona at the [__] la rams
the rams are given three are you kidding
me or what counting down to the super
bowl 56 new customers can get 56 to one
odds on any wild card game when they wet
a dollar five dollars
five dollars will win you 280 dollars
in free bets five hours to make the
weddings and you guys [__] good get
the [__] package if the sports book
isn't available in your state yet that's
fine we still got something to play for
with the wild card weekend everyone can
play for huge cash prizes with
draftkings daily fantasy football
contest draftkings is giving all new
customers a free shot at millions of
[__] dollars in total prizes
with their first deposit also
new york state
congratulations
we're alive and kicking draft king
sportsbook in the big bad apple buffalo
rochester [__] you name it draftkings
is there so do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app use promo code
joey and get 56 to one odds that's promo
code joey this wild card week at
draftking sportsbook must be 21
new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado new customers only
minimal final deposit a dollar wager one
per customer restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now if you got a gaming problem i wanted
to take a timeout called 1-800 gambler
but if not
let's make some [__] guidance
with draftkings the joint is also
brought to you by one of my personal
favorites c b
d
lion the best cbd on the market how do i
know because i live off this [__] let me
tell you something i had a bar of
chocolate the other night that dark
chocolate they have the next morning i
woke up i had a crick in my neck when i
went to sleep the next morning i woke up
like a pigeon that neck was going all
over the place
that cbd lion stop wasting your time
buying [__] cbd at a liquor store
knock it off go to cbdline.com read the
third party lab results
you see something you like they'll even
match you with what you're looking for
preston joey joint church and get 20 off
the liberty house they got a great new
from the back balls to the cream i can't
stress
cbd line enough press it go to
cbdline.com
press in joey join or church and get 20
off to live at diaz that's it and that's
that it's time to start this
[__] podcast i'll see you guys
afterwards
come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here on a beautiful
[__] monday morning
january the 17th it's colder than [__]
out there not really they said it was
like the [__] weather people loved to
scare [__] in uh america they started
torturing us like last tuesday big
snowstorm it's gonna i woke up this
morning i woke up sunday morning [__]
dick i'm waiting for [__] you know a
snowman out there it was nothing the sun
was out with 24 [__] degrees it could
still snow
then it got cloudy then towards the end
of the day it started raining
now today we got a little slush out
there nothing too [__] serious but
it's still
a [__] beautiful day to be
alive i had a great [__] weekend
hanging out my family i called a little
jiu jitsu class on saturday i worked out
friday night had a nice dinner with
jimmy and the boys we ate some chinese
food over at empire [__]
szechuan tremendous you understand me i
gained a couple pounds but i [__] them
out the last few days i was backed up
from the covert when i threw the [__]
kitchen sink at it my stomach was [__]
up i had to drink uh
probiotics for a few days
and then i went and i deadlift and
everything [__] came out i'm still
not at fighting weight i'm probably like
five pounds over but i'm tip top
[__] magoo i'm on my way i want
to tell you guys something i've been
getting questions from a lot of you guys
sending me emails asking me about that
you saw a journal
on instagram or some [__]
that says you know you could it's a
homemade journal whatever
and it has different things to get you
enthused and all this stuff
i looked at it guys it's 48 [__]
dollars for a notebook with directions
if you want i'll take 28 and i'll send
you a notebook with a picture of my
nutsack in it or some [__] like that are
you [__] [__] you ain't paying 48
for a [__] notebook to journal that's
not gonna happen right now it's the same
thing it just like has you checking like
it's social [__] media listen
journaling is journaling it's just
sitting there in the morning and dumping
whatever in your [__] heart whatever
is hanging on a fence that's bothering
you maybe you lost an hour sleep over it
you know a couple last week there was a
night where i got an email
from an agent and i looked and i go i
don't know what the [__] he's looking at
and that night
i slept well i slept like seven hours
but i could have slept like nine and i
got up early and i was like that's
what's bothering me it wasn't bothering
me
it was just that he sent an email it
didn't bother me at all
but i journaled about it that morning
and i felt a lot better and it's so
weird that afternoon i started getting
emails from like i got like two emails
and they're like there's a journal on
instagram is that what you're talking
about no i'm talking about go to [__]
cvs and buy a notebook buy a three
[__] uh chapter notebook the ones
with the binders the first chapters
you know buy four of them because you're
gonna need one for every quarter
so the first one is like your daily
routines what you you know you're
journaling what's going on with you
maybe you're thinking about your mother
or something like that maybe your father
maybe your girlfriend cheated on you
write down the specifics break it down
read it that's what the therapy part of
it is you're reading it once you read it
back it should make you feel a certain
way and you don't read it that day you
read it a couple [__] days later at
the end like i read all mine on friday
on friday morning i write my journal on
that night for like 10 minutes it takes
you just go through it i write a page a
[__] day it's that easy i don't want
you to spend 48 [__] dollars for a
notebook chapter 2 could be your [__]
goals
you know i want to do better at jiu
jitsu i want to lose 20 pounds i want to
go back to school what do i need to do
to go back to school well i got even if
it's that much simple i don't give a
[__] it's that simple i want you to
break it down into steps so you know
exactly what steps you've conquered i
got to get my ged
i got to get my mother to sign on the
school loan you know i got to do all
this [__] thing but you don't want it
to rattle in your head so just write it
down hey i don't give a [__] if you
think i'm [__] i do that i just
write it down what do i need to write a
book i gotta outline i gotta think of
the stories and i gotta journal because
i gotta figure out
what stories i wanna use and what you
know how does this apply to my [__]
story so
i do all this [__] and i've been doing
it for
i think since 1994 when jim handy taught
me how to do it i usually would put
jim handy on the podcast this time of
the year i did it about
you know three years in a row when i
first started the podcast it's not that
he wrote a book on goals or anything he
just read it and he turned me on to it
in a way that
it helped me throughout it helped me
with [__] comedy you know like it
makes you
how do you get better at this well i
gotta go there 55 [__] sets a month
but when i did stand up every [__]
beginning of the month i pull open the
page what do i want from this month okay
this month i want to book a guest star
and then i would that would be one then
a and b would be what do i need to do to
book that headshot i need to go online
and see what's going on i need to send
more pictures i need to get my reel in
order put [__] this on it take this
off you know you don't want to send a
reel that's you in 2004
completely different with blonde hair
that's not going to get you the [__]
job so it's little things like that what
can i do for comedy i gotta write five
minutes a day i gotta put together 15
minutes every weekend when you keep
yourself to the [__] grind that hard
results will come but if you monitor
them
the growth is [__] tremendous the
other day i was at jiu jitsu
and after jiu-jitsu went to get
something next door to eat that bagel
boy on the 516. that [__] they
ain't [__] around in there not that i
ate it but it's [__] good i ate it
last time i'm trying to cut down this
time last time i wanted i had a double
chicken cutlet sandwich on italian
with american cheese
[__] bacon and french dressing that
puts it over the [__] top that is a
tremendous sandwich with a snapple iced
tea
stop where you gonna get that type of
love from you understand me bagel boy on
the 516 they ain't [__] around dog if
you want to be a fat [__] they got the
answer but i usually when i go with the
guys after [__] you just i got a
cucumber salad you know me i don't eat
the cucumbers i just inhale the onions
and i tell them to give me extra [__]
tomatoes i ain't stupid i get those
cucumbers all right if you're gonna put
them on your eyeballs or something like
that which i need to put one of those
[__] on my eyeball i'm getting
[__] uglier and and older by the
[__] day and now that i started
getting high again guys it's every man
to himself
i'm back to my if you're not high before
two o'clock go [__] your mother campaign
i'm back on it i already got high this
morning at 11 o'clock
i'll get high when i come back from the
gym
i added [__] smoking dope before i go
on the treadmill
it used to take like he used to struggle
to get me to 30 minutes
i see the weights and i'm like i should
be lifting oh friday night
i got super stoned i did like three hits
off that freeze pipe the bubbler and i
went down and i put ac dc power rage on
from beginning to end i did the whole 40
minutes
[__] from uh kicked in the teeth
again
sin city i i got to tell you something
ac dc power rage
is a bad [__] album i was
looking for today to make it the album
of the week on patreon i don't think i
have it i think i left it to somebody
but that's a bad [__] album i
downloaded it from itunes on my phone so
i put the little earplugs in and i just
walked like a gagootz but i got to tell
you something man when you [__] walk
on that treadmill after you hit that
pipe three times first of all i've
always been a firm believer especially
for me
especially for me that you have to
i smoke a little bit before i go to the
gym but the last year and a half i
haven't been doing it i wanted to be a
nice person i didn't want to walk in
there smoking like cheech and chung
but now like if i have to go to the gym
at 11 i smoke like a 20 to 11
drink a little [__] liquid iv the
cherry the grape flavored tremendous and
i had it tastes like pedialyte you know
what i'm saying but you drink it it's
good for you i started drinking it when
i had the [__] cover the liquid iv
tremendous i love the [__] cherry and
i love the grape i go down there what do
you joey we don't give a [__] about
grape drink tell us something we don't
know about it's monday [__]
can i listen i started watching the wire
a few weeks
ago and i'm [__] blown away like i
love good tv i love all this [__] but i
started watching hawaii and i was
watching me and my wife watching two
episodes a night in fact
last week one day i broke my rule and we
even watched one like before dinner like
we're like we can't even wait for that
episode let's see what the [__] happened
to kemah
so
i mean when you like a show this much it
just blows me away so you know i go on
i'm a [__] nerd for tvs and [__] i go
on imdb and i [__] read who's in the
movie and i realized my buddy was in it
dominic lombardosi [__] good friend
of mine i love him with all my heart you
know i had dominic on last year and it a
lot of you guys i was in shock because
you weren't responsive to it but then
again i was out of my mind my interview
and skills were low and i usually
interview somebody when i have something
specific
like a lot of people always tell me joy
can i get on the podcast and i go give
me a week or two so i can think about
what angle to attract you and then
there's some people that i just like
when i had chris shift on i didn't have
an angle i didn't know much about the
foo fighters and how they got together
and what planet they came from so
there's situations like that where you
learn not to have something on the
podcast unless you really really know
their background or you're really really
a fan i've always been a fan of dominic
limbaugh doji's but i called him up the
air and i said dom i'm watching the wire
again i'm [__] blown away i want to
tap into some of the you know the
details and the wire and stuff like that
he said absolutely so
without further ado it's my main man
it's monday a little monday chat with
dominic lombardosi and i'll be back in a
little while to wrap it up and then i'll
come wednesday and do the solo one and
talk to you about my hemorrhoids what
you people want to hear but today it's
me and [__] dominic i hope you enjoy
this little chit chat about the wire
stay black
[Music]
there he is what's the story dom
happy new year my brother happy new year
welcome to uncle joey's joint monday
morning how are you my friend
good man you
[__] putting the pieces together you
know
i'm [__] trying i gained some weight
after the
uh the covet because i started drinking
cranberry juice and orange i don't drink
[__] juice anymore they told you 10
years ago i had to drink juice
so i gained a couple pounds but you know
what jiu jitsu walking around i love the
treadmill
and uh that's it just try i'm enjoying
fatherhood for the first time
i'm happy for you it's uh
it looks so you look so relaxed yeah
that's it looks like you have uh
i don't want to say like you don't you
don't have a care in the world because i
i know we all do we all do uh you you
you you radiate that you know that's out
there you know you exude that so doc it
was a long time it's nice just to
[__] be a human being
yeah i was never a [__] human being
as sad as that is i was always
you know and then comedy and then
you know i got a girlfriend and then you
feel half a human and she talks you into
using your insurance
and uh
you know what i'm saying you got
insurance go take care of yourself
yeah
oh you mean i could use this
yeah yeah so it's like been
a great [__] journey i tell you what
i never thought i'd say this but it's
great to be back on the east coast
and the [__] story
um we we've had some sidebar
conversations you know and uh
i didn't think you were gonna come back
east i actually thought you were gonna
do like that migration like to texas or
with florida or whatever where people
are going and um
uh
i'm happy you're comfortable you just
seem happy and if you're happy i'm happy
i had a feeling that what was about to
happen you needed to be grounded
by family
you know now i have no family
but the kids i grew up with a family
i got two guys 20 minutes from here i
got a guy around the corner
i see them every couple days but we talk
every day
and they keep me grounded my daughter's
godfather i grew up with it's just nice
i'm nice around the people that
when they tell you something you know
they're gonna do it they're not blowing
smoke up your ass it's just nice it's
very nice man
so
it's i never thought i'd be back here
i never [__] saw it
well i mean you know i i i i personally
could understand why
you know um
sometimes it's hard going back where you
grew up
you know there's a reason why we we
wanted to leave you know
um
i get it
i get it without going into details
because i know your history you know and
if anybody follows uh
joey
knows his background knows how he grew
up knows about his family knows about
his neighborhood and um
could understand why he possibly
wouldn't go back i couldn't be in that
neighborhood but i could be close by
yeah
and now my belly closed yeah the [__]
the one nice childhood deli closed about
10 years ago
so we transferred over to a different
deli guy's tremendous tony
great guy and now he closed this deli
so it's like a i don't even need to go
up there anymore i just sit down here
but i gotta be honest with you during
this pandemic
i've dipped into every well i can to
stay entertained
as a comic i watched all the specials
then you go through
the netflix stuff and then you go to the
sopranos again and all the [__] the
punisher i watch some great shows
was sitting here about three weeks ago
and my wife goes this [__] wire is
sticking out on
on hbo did you ever watch it and i go
terry
with comedy and drugs i don't know what
the [__] i watched i had to and i'm
gonna tell you what happened to me yeah
like i with comedy and the drugs and the
weed i don't know what the [__] i want
right in yeah don't worry like i was
lost dominic and then me and my wife had
to talk and she's i go tyree how was
this 2002
to 2008 and she's like joey
yeah yeah you got to remember hbo was on
fire and she started reading off you
guys the wire sopranos sex and the city
carnaval
she just started spitting out all these
shows uh you know that hbo had so i i
got caught like i never watched if you
think i watched the pilot of the
sopranos in the first season
i was in cleveland
making [__] crazy people laugh i
didn't [__] know
so i played catch up the whole time i
remember what this is how [__] up i
was in the drugs and life
i remember watching the wire
but i got it confused with one of those
nbc shows
i think did you get it confused with the
shield
no the other one with the gun a lot of
people do i think people come up to me
man i love you on
that's the worst when people get you
confused from a movie
with chiklis yeah yeah with checklists
no no this was the one with i'm not even
kidding it happens all the time oh i
could just imagine i was lying i'm not
lying i could just [__] imagine and
when people want to believe what they
want to believe
when people would come up to me i had a
couple ones that told me i was a liar
that was big [__]
and started arguing with me on a set i
was [__] spider-man
i'm on the set of sony and these family
walks by and they take a double take
they're doing like the tour of sony they
were from brooklyn or some
mr surprise i'm not him i'm sorry i'm
joey diaz they kept turning around
looking at me going [__] you
you're a [__] embarrassment to
italian say who the [__] you are
i'm like you want to see my license no
it's a phony
they thought i was already passed
so in all this hoopla i started watching
the wire i knew you were in it i got it
confused with some show on nbc with the
guy with the bad skin
the [__] comedian that was in
scarface he was on svu with me we got
into an argument on the set and they
[__] asked him to go home because he
like i
i was 400 pounds he's trying to pull me
off from under a car with i don't know
what sled but there's snow on the floor
i'm telling him an ice cube look i'm
stuck on the [__] tire here and he
kept pulling he's like i'm gonna hurt my
back you're [__] you should've told me
hey relax we got into a little argument
even though i knew him
and then
he said
yeah he was in scarface he read the
[__] thing when tony was in the car
he was the one that was on stage bowser
richard belzer oh yeah
yeah so i got all that [__] confused and
then anyway we put the [__] wire on
and by episode five
uh we were both hooked
we're watching the the pilot was the
first episode was [__] tremendous it
just takes you there
and then i like after episode five we
looked at each other and said what the
[__] is this and now we're on episode
with season three
and i'm like i gotta call [__] don
yeah that's uh
break this [__] down for me and then
we're gonna come back when this when i
finish the season and break it down for
me again how did you book this how did
you find out about this give me a
[__] process here okay
um
2000 uh
uh 2021
[Music]
you know 2000 2001 because yeah i
remember i just got back from paris or
something like that and
and um
there was the audition for this thing
now originally
they were recurring characters herc and
carver were recurring characters
so i i i went i read for alexa fogle
there was one producer
um his name is robert you see his name
all over the place um
robert f colesbury
beautiful human being great producer
produced movies like the natural
um
and he also produced 61 that i did with
billy crystal okay maybe three years
prior to that
and
so that's the only familiar name i knew
on there so i went and i read they
called me back and i wind up getting the
part
audition
auditioned again
and i got it
now mind you not a regular recurring
supposed to be maybe who knows does five
episodes six but he's doing the pilot
we went there went to baltimore
um
[Music]
it looked like a bomb hit the place
i mean well baltimore looks like now did
not look like in 2001 no
very much like the show
very very much
you know
actually not even sugarcoating it that's
what it was
and um
all the actors from day one
from day one when we were all in that
hotel
i've never forget the redness uh the ren
uh the
renaissance hotel um
in baltimore
um
we all
got along
we all got along
and it continued
for five seasons
you all got along man i'm telling you we
were like a family we stayed like a
family until this day
it shines through
it and uh
yeah and then i remember doing the show
i remember shooting the pilot
like this
i don't know uh you know i don't know if
this is gonna get picked up yeah you
know i remember doing the ride alongs
and
and the first time they they made us do
a ride along was with the homicide cops
i'm like this is not like what we're
doing so they they put us with these
narcs
and and
totally different ball game
two ways of policing
completely different completely a
completely different animal
and i said all right
and
me and me and seth who plays carver
um
did our thing
you know and then when the show wind up
getting picked up
we lived together the first season
the same apartment
like a college dorm who came in who
wanted to smoke weed you smoke weed you
stayed over there if you wanted to play
madden you stayed over there you wanted
to just drink and [__] you stayed at
the table
that's what it was our door was always
open to everybody
and
when i went to work with seth it just
was it was like uh it was like this uh
okay
and we just was easy
not that it was easy but working with
seth was easy
laughing joking we understood each other
we we understood each other's timing
it just that's the way that's it just
was a great that was my college
that was my college when it came to
acting
i was never formally trained i was never
institutionally trained
uh
i was institutionally trained
yeah a couple of brothers taught me how
to happen no i i just um
you know acting is weird you know you
you you act with people who who have
degrees in acting you know and and and
all that so
that just wasn't my my route
but
i always tell people who are old enough
if they remember the apex tech for
school yes
uh commercial apex remember that guy
no you remember the guy yeah
you learn a trade you learn a tool when
you learn the tool that goes in your
toolbox remember that yes that's what
acting was for me
exactly just like that
and uh the wire
was college
the talented people i couldn't believe
it all the people in there though
yeah they were all
much more experienced than me and i and
i had to figure things out
i had to figure things out and i had to
figure them out quick
last night just to let you know about
setting you last night you're sitting in
a car
you're waiting for the longshoreman to
make a move and you're eating
and you're like i'm done with mike can i
get some of your fries and he goes what
do you mean also you started eating his
fries and he goes you know what you're a
fat [__] and you're like you think i'm
fat
just kidding
but while you're saying it to him you're
eating the [__] fry you're like you
think i'm bad and i'm dying a laughter
right there i'm like no okay so in a way
because you guys are a comic relief you
are but i didn't i loved how they used
you
i loved how they used your comic relief
you know
i loved all that [__] when oh my god
when you took the deposit for the 1200
and you put the bug in the ball and the
ball got run over by the [__] truck
oh my god god all that [__] it's it
balances it's like i really loved the
writing
the [__] writing was look at the
names look at the names of the writers
as the episodes pass you by
and you're like he wrote an episode for
this show
richard price dennis lehane
george pelicanos
i mean
these guys are just uh over my you know
it's just like
david
was
has has such a great system i love
working on his production whether it's
whether whether it's the wire or whether
it was the deuce
or what i i i i did a day he called me
to to to come and do a day on uh we
owned this city
and um i just look because
it's on the page man
it's on the page
and
you just have to finesse it or bring
whatever colors you want to it or
whatever your process is and and that's
what it is and
um but there's something to be said
when the bible
is right
and on the wire the bible was right
you know um whichever avenue you took to
get that through whatever you needed to
to to uh to bring it to the to
to the forefront
that's up to you but it's on the page
i mean um
one of my favorite scenes
uh is the scene
where i console
or i i wouldn't say console but it's
probably the only time
in retrospect
that you see herc
be kind
is with bodhi's grandmother
when they raid and they're turning oh
yes yes yes
real early in the show yeah you go and
he says to you what the [__] were you
doing in there
right you were very gentle and you know
what i remember getting shaken down by
cops in time and there was one cop that
came back and goes hey
we're sorry about this you know not
nothing personal
but the show is very unapologetic
as you watch this show you're gonna
realize
um
people don't change
people are who they are you know you
watch a show and
a lot of people sort of have this
epiphany
and they change their life and
all
their bad qualities are
miraculously gone
doesn't happen in this world
does not happen
i played a character for five years who
more or less was a bully
when he needed to be
who worked outside of the lines
yes he tried he was doing it to bring
down drug dealers
you know it's not like he was doing it
to rob old ladies or whatever but it
doesn't justify what he was doing he
wasn't able to work within the
guidelines in order to make a case or
bring up a wire
but
if you notice and that we could we could
have this conversation when you finish
the show
because
you're going to say
you know
hurricane carver that [__] ups did this
that that but
i have a rebuttal for that sometimes
because i've heard it enough time
but um
there's no
hope
in the show
anybody
who represents hope
doesn't make it
and you see that
you're on season three you're with
amsterdam bonnie colvin has been
introduced i think it's just robert f
wisdom who you should definitely have
on your pod because i mean
even his history
rastafarian and
and bob marley i mean you know man i
don't even want to give it away but um i
i would i would love to facilitate that
for you because you should have them on
your show i love keema and i'll help you
out anyway yeah
i love keema
gamer i love keema
i like what she's going through right
now with the with the [__] wife and
the the she's pregnant and she don't
want to be a cop and on the other end
you got the smooth
chief the the the thin brother
that could pass
and he's going through the same thing
with his wife and my head i'm watching
this going i've never seen a show where
they're showing you what's going on at
home
now as a cop
joey do you realize this um
this show
is
it
shows
everybody every race every class
everybody in all different stages
whether you could be white and corrupt
you could be white in the nice part you
could be on the street and have a heart
you could have a badge all the
credentials all the stripes on your
sleeves and be the
be just as bad as the person that you're
trying to incarcerate
you could be a politician you'll get to
that later
but you see it
you see the breakdown you see the
breakdown of the social fabric because
the show
is
the star of the show is baltimore
baltimore represents every little
american city in the united states
you understand yeah so
that
is why that show
resonated should have resonated back
then and it resonates even more so
today it's i'm watching it and it's like
it happened yesterday let's get this out
of the way almost like it's timeless and
and
david
david simon
nina
uh
big shout out to ed burns robert f coles
barry all the writers all the producers
who have played on that show
and um
they're a genius
now let's get to the other side of this
because let me tell you something to
fill that void
whoever did the casting
i'll suck his dick or her dick
the casting is wait you don't know you
don't know alexa fogle no i'm a
ballerina
stuff nothing
she is
nothing you are she's new you are ever
cast that show when i see that chubby
black dude
with the dredge that's a drug deal like
a kingpin and his own that uh
proposition joe proposition joe the
casting on him
soul he passed away but god bless god
the acting on that dude
unreal his look
the casting when he's eaten
no you know it just shows i mean
snoop come
no snoop not yet
with omar
not yet snoop dogg
no the girl snoop
no she hasn't been in yet now
we have another
yeah we haven't even gotten the [__]
omar i decided early on
with all the television i've watched
everything movies
i think one of my favorite [__] bad
guys right now
hands down is omar when he comes into
the projects and he goes oh
the big bad wolf and he's like don't
make me come up there he [__] the
shotgun
and it's like a six second now like
maybe 20-second pause and you're like
why isn't anybody shooting this
[__] from a window but instead a
bag of crack falls out of a [__]
window and lands next to him and you're
like holy [__]
the writing
is second to none
i like
that they didn't make the longshoremen
italian
that would have been the easy route
yeah and that that's not the case in
baltimore and baltimore right it's not
the case they made them polish and
whatever
uh greek
you know i like all
dog and even that guy not the guy the
guy that played the greek
has been in a thousand things
who the old man the old man which guy
are you talking about the glasses that
they want to see him all the time
the the longshoremen want to keep seeing
him and finally he shows up an old guy
he was on miami talking about paul ben
victor or bill raymond
then there's a little guy that he was in
casino oh no he was in uh
the irishman
he was in the irishman the dude there's
two dudes that play the greek the one
dude is the one that talks
my boy everybody loves raymond and
pacino to invest in this hotel in vegas
come on what can we do here for us
the guy that you uh
you see you remember
you played in the the three stooges as
well
i thought that's where you were going no
no no no i'm a three stooges
[Applause]
i love all that [__] channel six miami
in the summers
i'd be in at four to watch my boy
now the the actual greek the the the guy
who is the greek
bill raymond
i just finished working with though he
played my father on um i did a show uh a
limited series for hbo called mrs
fletcher
and he played my dad
i'm telling you it's crazy and i worked
with him 20 years ago
you know
just everybody in there the guy that
plays
the longshoreman that
the cop wants to take down that guy i've
seen him do some great [__] work
yeah you know everybody in that movie
everybody in that tv show is doing great
work and here's where like after the
last week's episodes i watched with my
wife
we actually had a discussion that
this show might be as good as the
[__] sopranos if you're looking at it
from where i'm standing
it's debatable it depends where your
preference is very debatable but the
writing is second to none
the way they go into the show
different [__] completions that's why
that's why when people come up to me and
they say that i i just basically look i
don't i don't really classify things
like that
i don't know i don't know just because
uh
hey i don't know it just uh it's just it
makes me feel a little uneasy to you
know i know there are shows
that i like
that i love
um whether they be the honeymooners the
odd couple
game of thrones
sopranos mad men see i think mad men is
a genius that's a good show my wife it's
more my wife she turned me on to it
um
and then you know sitcoms i love sitcoms
mike and molly everybody loves raymond
you know i i just love
watching people act i love
i love film and i love tv i love
watching people act
when it's something that like when i
watch the y i'm learning
i'm taking notes not that i'm going to
work you know anytime soon but i'm
taking notes i did it
i'm looking i'm going jesus christ look
you know the thing that opens me up to i
love watching stuff that opens me up
and takes me away while i'm watching and
i still remember going to cop weed on
178th in
amsterdam and there were cubans in 1984
and i'm like i would go to every day
and one day they saw me speaking english
they didn't think i spoke out i was
talking english and the one guy came
home he's like hey you
you want to sell nickelbacks whilst i go
yeah why not and i stood out there for
like a week
until i realized that i was getting 25
for every 25 nickel bags that i sold i
had to sell 25 nickel bags when i make
and i'm like what the [__] are they
doing so one day i went there he gave me
my 25 nickel bags
and i'm gonna go up the block and catch
the people by the light the guy goes
that's a good idea
i went up by the lightning because you
go up there it was like 10 in the
morning i sold three bags and i just
kept walking to 178
to the port authority i stopped at
[__] uh the gambling joint upstairs
i lost 20 and i got on the bus back to
jersey and i never cop over there and
then i went to san francisco
and i lived a block away from the haight
ashbury and again they were all cubans
that come over marielle
and i spoke english they're like help us
out so i'm on a corner with these guys
hiding coke in the bumpers
hiding weed and the bumpers [__]
it was there was a trance not a trans he
was a guy
a cuban dude that only [__] half
[__] like cuban ones that just put
makeup on and they put like two bags for
their tits and he would have them out
there slinging
right so you went up to him gave him the
ten bucks and he would have two men
dressed as woman slinging with a wig on
and heels and the whole thing and if
they [__] up he would backhand them
and the wig would fall off
it was [__] tremendous it was right
off his show so when i watched this [__]
i remember like oh my god this is as
real
as it [__] gets
yeah
i mean that that sort of lifestyle
has been kind i don't want to say it's
been like romanticized but
the streets anybody who's been in the
streets anybody who's who's been in
their car 3 30 4 o'clock in the morning
and now i've been in the best
neighborhood really knows what goes down
so really scary [__] goes down to some
like um
[Music]
i mean i i i i've seen a lot you know
and uh
you're like how do you come back
you don't come back to being treated
like that and they you have to
you know you have to some of these
people have to even like watch that sad
man even watching michael b jordan in
there
like you're still friends with him like
he was 12 13 14 15 whatever the [__]
i'm like wow look at the acting no
wonder this kid became who he was
this guy was around [__]
so the show just [__] rattles me i
love you with all my heart but it makes
me love you more like you know
my wife and i were talking and mercy was
in the room
so we were watching you know i can't
have my daughter in my room for the
while no no no but it gets it gets
richer joe
see
season three season four
it
you know season two
a lot of us were light
um season one we were very heavy season
two was predominantly
um
the uh the uh the longshoremen and all
that
and a lot of us didn't have much to do
like if you notice in the second season
i'm doing a lot of surveillance
we're in the car we're on the boxes
we're here
which was kind of a blessing in disguise
because we got to work every day all the
time we every time we came to work we
did second unit without robert f
goldsberry
and then
bob
winded up passing away
during uh season two going into season
three which by the way we never knew we
were gonna have because um
hbo
was never really
that hot with the wire you know so uh
david always had to pull the rabbit out
of the hat
and we had some supporters there like
carolyn strauss at the time who really
believed in the show and i and
we we kept getting another season but
it was like oh we're done
that's it
um
very much in the shadows of a lot of
those shows at the time um you've
mentioned a few you know like six feet
under sopranos sex in the city when sex
in the city was on sopranos was on six
feet under was on any other
you didn't know about it
nobody knew about the wire when we were
doing it it wasn't until later on and
then
um
we we the show had never gotten
nominated
never um
david
i don't think david got nomi i mean he
won a peabody award but he never got
nominated
michael k neville
idris
uh
wendell pierce
and wendell how many things have i seen
wendell pearson
a very very good friend of mine a very
dear friend of mine send him my love i'm
a big [__] fan of him i think
beautiful laugh
he he's
you know he's great
he's
and he's a beautiful human being man
and the other african-american detective
god damn he's good the one that figures
[__] out in the beginning
in the first season he's like the quiet
guy he collects he makes hand
and he was in the pawn shop division
that guy is a velvet [__] hammer
and that's what i like i like to see
acting
i don't want to go see no offense to
anybody antonio banderas i expect him to
be a [__] good actor
but when you put
a cast like that together i know some
guys
and i don't know some guys and guess
what the guys i don't know i'm falling
in love with aka oh i watched zorro last
night
which one come up with antonio
no [__] i'm just thinking about some
dude that's spanish so nobody will come
back at me and say you hate latinos and
[__]
[__] people he could have picked
he came out with antonio banderas
cause i remember i was on a plane one
time with rogan
and he was passed the [__] out broken
gets on a plane and passes out if you
think really oh my god you got him for
two minutes
i've seen him pass before the plane
takes off
really yeah and then he'll wake up
mid-flight
and he'll go on the computer for a
couple minutes
he won't touch the food and he'll go
back to bed
so he would get his food and i'd get
mine i'd eat mine pick at his and then
one day on a trip back if you have to
hunt this block down
i blew a fart next to him on a [__]
plane in first class
that smelled like 10 dead bodies and it
was one of those hot farts and he came
out of a coma it was that bad that he
woke up i have a coma still looking at
me all weird like you know people look
at you when they're in a deep sleep and
they smell so like it must have gone
into his soul and he was looking around
and when he looked on the screen antonio
banderas was dancing with a bunch of
black kids in harlem some movie he made
and the next day rogan wrote on a blog
[__] diaz needs to go see a doctor
he farted he woke me up and when i ride
oh my god he goes i went to look and it
was antonio banderas dancing with a
bunch of [__] urban kids or something
i was dying
what do you normally do like if you have
uh
a long flight
like say you have a 10 hour 11 hour i've
never had those i can't handle that [__]
i'll jump out of a [__] plane
so if you had to fly from new york to
hawaii what would you do stop in la
first
i would break it up
you know i'd break it up a little bit i
don't want to be on a [__] plane for
11 [__] hours so i'd go to la break
it up a little bit maybe get something
to eat at the airport
go outside smoke a half a number breathe
a little bit and go back in and get on
the flight
go back to security yeah two hours two
hour delay is perfect i don't give a
[__]
that back is gonna hurt anyway
so you better walk around the airport
for two hours get something to eat they
got a couple good places to eat at lax
then you shoot to hawaii on the flight
to hawaii though that's when you put the
mickey in the thing if you got roofies
every man for himself you know what i'm
saying because you want to sleep that
last six gets on you could read i could
watch
two episodes of narcos two wires
and look through my emails and [__] for
a little while
maybe switch the uh news on the plane
and then that's it i'm ready to get the
[__] off the plane
yeah i time it in my head so i go to la
i get off i walk around take a piss
maybe buy a disney shirt i'm not leaving
the airport
i'm not leaving the [__] airport
that's not going to happen
and then i get back on the plane why not
why wouldn't you
um
today in today's l.a
in today's la no
in today's la no oh
i would land in vegas for a detour
and go vegas to hawaii
and get a nice steak stretch out
all you need is a two-hour stretch out i
want to get to hawaii and get this party
started
right so i need to stretch out maybe a
cup of wonton soup get back on the plane
and that's when you dose that
[__]
that's when you give that indian that
gin you know what i'm saying we're going
deep for [__] because i was gonna
take my family to hawaii everybody goes
to hawaii
but when i went online it was six hours
or five and a half hours from california
i'm from l.a yeah and i'm like i'm not
going through this [__] i'd rather go to
new york anyway i got to go down there
and
get a [__] attack by a shark
yeah
but when are you going that flight i've
done that flight a few times it's a
great flight but i'd rather get off and
stretch my back i've done it from new
york to hawaii okay straight
straight 11.
uh 11
yeah about 11 yeah 11 11 hours and 15
minutes
you cocktail
yeah yeah couple cocktails yeah i don't
cocktails it would be
horrible for me to you know like if i
cocktailed it would be i could see me
[__]
lighting
everybody to do it in first class you
got to have the pod you got to lay down
i mean no i definitely would take a jet
blue
whatever that that's what i would that's
the other thing if you're flying from
new york there's not that many flights
that fly out there i think there's only
united and hawaii uh hawaiian airlines
that go direct
a few other ones that that do stops
multiple stops but then you know that
that's jumps it up to like 16 hours
i gotta ask you one thing
when
you know it's 2002 to 2008 we're talking
about 2022
and i know that we have different
feelings for work we've done
how you felt about something when you
went on a set in 2005 is completely
different
in 2022 you look at that as a different
movie
maybe was it growing when you look back
at your work in the wyatt
what do you say to yourself
i don't look at my work
um
i think of the experience i think of of
uh the people that i met the
relationships that i that i still hold
to today i cherish those i'm grateful
for those
at the work i don't know i don't know i
really uh work was beautiful from what
i've seen already
the work is beautiful i could see how
i i know that if anybody would go on
that show for five years
whatever you think you walked in there
you walk out a different [__] soldier
yeah you know you gotta what's that
expression you gotta
sharpen with metal if you want to be
metal
that show
was as metal
as it gets
i don't think there was a weak link i'm
looking now for a weak link and i can't
find it the kid that sells the coke his
little african-american partner
everybody is [__] strong like
everybody
it gets richer okay
listen we're gonna have you back in a
couple of weeks back
yeah especially this season
i think you're gonna find very
interesting
only because of your past because of
places you have traveled
um
things that are trying to be implemented
in this season i don't want to give
anything but no i'm looking forward i
really really think you're gonna dig the
season and i know for a fact
season one and season four are my
favorites
okay i can tell you that
maybe not by seeing it but by by work uh
my work experience
those those seasons and
i almost have like a photograph i like
because i'm dyslexic i read things and i
understand the very clear because i read
them slow and i have to read them
multiple times
but i remember i remember the story
lines i remember uh the a star and i b
storyline the c star i remember all that
you could say episode uh
for this one
you just have to tell me what was going
on and i could tell you what was going
on in the episode even though i didn't
see it
i will watch three and four episodes and
i might make notes
season three and four i'll make some
notes and next time you come on great
characters getting introduced oh my god
from what you're saying from what i've
seen great characters get oh wait
you're in store for some really good
ones if you know anything about me i
love this type of [__] i love
watching that type of show from a to z
it's as interesting
for me as anything i've ever watched
well a lot a lot of this comes from
you know
if you ever went on the internet and
um i don't know i don't know but if you
if you look at
um simon's treatment
for this
right
if you look at
what he had to write in order to sell
this show
it's so intricate
it's online
so yeah you could see it
and it's so detailed
that when you watch the show and you and
you read that
it pretty much mirrors itself i mean
there's a few variations here and there
but
pretty much solid
the realness and the authenticity that
this show has also comes from the fact
that david simon was an investigative
reporter
for the baltimore sun
he was in the streets
he talked to these guys he knew these
guys he knew the ins and outs
at burns
another producer writer was a homicide
detective for 25 years also a teacher
ex-military guy
you know
so the foundation for this show was all
there you know um
and
all that realism and all that stuff that
you talk about and everybody else talks
about is because
the people that were
who who uh created this show
started off with a really solid and
truthful foundation
and they just built from that you could
tell now that you're telling me who the
producers are
all real people some of these people are
real people clay david these are real
people bunk is a real cop that he knew
you know um
a lot of these a lot of these characters
are based off of
i'm sure there are certain liberties but
based off of people through his
experience as being an investigator
or
ed burns
um
you know um
being a homicide cop there really was an
avon box there
that's a great name it wasn't yvonne box
there you go
yeah
wood harris another great actor on the
show yes
been around forever too
forever forever ever him and his brother
steve
great actors
what is amazing in the show
so
under the radar just so there but so
consistent
he's so good i even like the sister his
sister that he has to that her son
supposedly killed himself in jail
that she plays like the sister she goes
to see that's another great character oh
my god barry gilliard d'angelo d'angelo
just tremendous the girl okay he met and
the stripper that did the angelo die yet
yes he okay
you know why d'angelo died why
because you represented hope
that's [__] crazy
joey okay
you're back in a few weeks i could
torture you and come back
yeah what do you got going on anything
um
i might have to hop on a 11 hour flight
okay
how soon
uh but i got i worked on a film called
reptile that should be coming out uh for
netflix uh
um next year but other than that you
know just um
trying to stay busy trying to stay
creative you know mom good everybody
good
i'm as as good as she could possibly be
you know she's hanging in there well my
heart goes out to you my in your family
i love your debt
and uh let's be in touch i love that you
came on today talk about this wow
[__] fired up i'm fired up about it
hey it's okay it's sunday i got somebody
else turning the sauce today okay well
let me take a picture of it
when i told my daughter she asked me
before she left who's going to be on the
podcast
so she goes let me see him i go you just
saw him you know she came down and
watched for a little while
so all your pictures came up on uh yahoo
but i clicked the one from fat tony and
she's like jesus what happened well
that's makeup mercy you know we started
talking
and then in the middle of all this you
know what my [__] daughter said
he goes i know him
he's the guy that built the [__]
house outside the
the tree house
because i called it down here to show
her the tree house
that's how we we we've been looking for
this photography i remember yeah yeah
she's like he's me and my wife are like
you see why you don't say [__] around
this little [__] this
dog she remembers [__] she's like he had
the tree house i'm like holy [__]
yeah so it's a small world happy new
year it's gotta come up man yeah you
know your hop skip jumping away man you
know you got to come up i love to come
up and see you brother do something in
this city i have not even been there
except for working and going to a movie
i'm not having done dick there
they say to stay away from midtown but
everything else is cool
oh i'm in westchester so perfect that's
even better than one nine one four
representing i'm through the tappan zee
you're and you're in uh yeah i'm real
close yeah
yeah yeah
i love you enjoy your sauce today
stay black all right brother thank you
all right my friend be one weeks three
weeks
okay
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoyed it dominic's a great guy
follow him on twitter we always
communicate on twitter he's a sweetheart
of a guy if you got a question about the
wire or you have a question about acting
that's the [__] and trust me he
will respond to you i don't care what
level you're at or whatever the [__]
you're doing
so do me a favor i love you
[__] with all my heart it's
monday baby don't buy that [__]
fugazi uh
journal to just get a [__] regular
notebook and that's all you're gonna
need it's monday [__] it's a
beautiful day to be alive regardless of
the [__] weather i'm tip top magoo
i'm a little stoned you can see that
obviously and i'm ready to go it's going
to be a great week i'll be back
wednesday ready to [__] rock all
right i love you [__] and now
a word for my tremendous sponsors
all right i want to thank you guys i
want to thank dominic lombardozi
i want to thank my sponsors you know me
i love draftkings i love freeze pipe but
most importantly i love cbd lion listen
if you need cbd you don't even know what
cbd is so i want you to go read first i
want you to be read about cbn cby
and cbd
go to cbdlion.com right now see how cbd
line could work for you whether it's a
basketball the kinesiology tape the
gummy bears
cbd line is the best so go to cbd line
right now pressing joey joint or church
and get 20 off delivered to your house
no more [__] cbd at the mall the
joint is also brought to you by
freeze pipe listen you got a nice cold
[__] hit every time why burn your
throat out like the rest of these
[__] maleux smoking a joint with that
dirty [__] fingers no no no freeze
pipe is the way to go it comes with a
detachable chamber and you freeze
beforehand you see what i'm saying when
you're ready to [__] see the devil
you'll put that [__] bung together
and it's easy if i could do it you could
do it whether it's the bubbler whether
it's the pipe or whether it's the bong
it's two little [__] pieces ba-boom
you smoke that [__] it's like
putting ice cubes in a bong but a lot
better you understand me
listen i was smoking joints for years
when i got the stuff from freeze pipe i
got another pipe until i tried it and
then
i knew was tremendous
if you want to start off with the pipe
go ahead you'll see the devil just like
i do on a daily not to mention the pipe
is non-toxic freezes faster than water
and stays frozen longer freeze pipe
cools down the smoke by hundreds of
degrees so listen joint listeners do me
a favor go to freezepipe.com
pressing code joey and save 10 percent
off your first order get your bong piper
bubbler today that's freeze pipe that's
the freezepipe.com
and press and go code joey to save you
if you could smoke it from
freeze pipe mason i like to also thank
draftkings listen not only is it nfl
[__] playoffs this week wildcard
playoff we got a ufc card on saturday
night so if you're looking
to have some fun and win some money
draftkings is the one for you the nfl
players are here draftking sportsbook
the official sports betting part of the
nfl is kicking things off with a huge
offer you bet five dollars you get 208
dollars in free bets joey how are they
gonna do that because they're giving you
56 to one odds out of respect for super
bowl 56 [__] suckers now if sports book
isn't available in your state yet no
problem
we still have something to play for this
wild card weekend that's draftkings
daily fantasy football contest win huge
cash [__] prizes draftkings is giving
all new customers a free shot of winning
a million dollars where you gonna get
that action from you know about football
you know about this you know about that
let's do this [__] put your knowledge to
the test
download the draftking sportsbook app
download the draftkings daily fantasy
football app and let's get started press
and download the app use promo code joey
j-o-e-y that's promo code joey this wild
car we can draftking sportsbook is going
to be insane
player props team props plus the ufc
plus [__] college basketball plus
hockey don't get me started you gotta be
21 older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
new customers only minimum final deposit
and a dollar wager required one per
customer restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details now if you
got a gaming problem call 1-800 gambler
but first head to draftkings and win
some [__] guitars i want to
thank draftkings i want to thank cbd
line i want to thank freeze pipe but
most importantly i want to thank you
savages for always having my back and
[__] listening on a monday morning i
love you [__] with all my heart
stay black i'm here have a good week and
i will see you guys wednesday
the 19th tip top magoo
you